[Applaudissements]
l'émission et surtout je reçois vraiment
un vraiment c'est un des garçons qui m'a
donné le plus envie de faire ce métier
je suis fan de lui depuis des années et
c'est matthieu delormeau et moi qui
surtout a nommé un an mes premiers pas
sur la gamme
oui
à jhagadia tags
la place à la trappe
maintenant d'accent
francois qc au fait scrat choses
complémentaires un petit qui voilà je
vous fais une entrée je vous dis
attention tous cas en passe très bon
c'est par masson lagarde fait une autre
en libye attention demain un micro mme
un ami commun alors micro mamie chrome à
celui la série comme les effets spéciaux
n'ai pas commencé et ce soir pour
présenter touche pas à mon pote vincent
lagaf
écrite
ce soir exceptionnellement bas via
quelque chose qu'on a pas l'habitude de
faire mais moi c'est venez ici vous
allez jouer hausse et plus c'est moi oui
j'adore vous avez ans et plus et ouais
vous allez gagner vous allez jouer pour
gagner les cheveux vous allez partir
quand la prochaine fournée pour las
vegas avec toute l'équipe de cyril
hanouna
c'est aussi ce soir vous allez devoir
deviner combien l'audience va être de
cyril hanouna hockey
le second vous êtes prête c'est parti tu
l'aimés chiffres du domaine
ici le micro tu donnes un million c'est
plus dans six mois
c'est plus ni aux trois c'est moi et moi
galles match de foot et à sang c'est
plus de 1950 c'est plus de 1000 chambres
de sang c'est moins 2 millions cent
soixante dix c'est presque ça c'est
gagné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non vincent lagaf qui la gérait cotonou
le brave monsieur
ça rigolait j'ai là j'ai l'impession
d'être à la communion d'un soleil